contact is not easy. But
nevertheless, in any case, the introduction of some
troops into direct contact in direct contact.
A clash with the Russian
army is a very dangerous step that
can lead to a global catastrophe.
I hope that those who talk
about this have enough intelligence to
not to take dangerous steps. They
must determine for themselves what is more important for them to
fulfill some kind of allied
obligations as they see it
or to
ensure the interests of their
own people of their national
interests Judging by because you said at
the forefront In this case,
apparently, some allied  then the
obligations
in this case of the Federal Republic
within the framework of the North Atlantic Alliance are
correct or not I believe that this is a
mistake
for this mistake the
business economies citizens of the Federal
Republic
with its interests are paying off Apparently few people
think otherwise they would not have undermined Nord
Stream 1 and Nord Stream  -2 Though they  didn’t
work, but it was such, as it
were, such an element of reliability that In
extreme cases it could be turned on,
but now there is no such possibility, although there is
one branch, as I said in Moscow,
it’s still apparently in working order, but a
decision
is not made Apparently, it’s unlikely
will be accepted, but this is no longer
our business, this is the business of our partners, we did
not set ourselves the task of destroying
Ukraine
No, of course, everything is fine